Welcome to "Ear Biscuits"
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time, I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett,
this week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're gonna be talking
about a birthday surprise
that I gave my wife.
You know what?
I would say you gave it to me too.
I gave it to Link.
And we wanna give it to you as well.
I'm not talking about,
the big surprise I'm talking about
is not the thing that came out
on the Rhett and Link channel,
the vlog where I became Jason Momoa
and Link also helped with that.
I became Jason Momoa.
I wouldn't characterize that
as you becoming Jason,
I would say you made a.
Valiant attempt?
A cringe adjacement, adjacent.
Adjacement?
That's not a word, a cringe
adjacent coffee table book
where you tried your best to.
It is on the coffee table,
thanks for noticing.
Oh, no it's not, is it?
I don't know where it is, actually.
You don't even know where it is?
Okay, first of all, let me just tell you.
Well, can I say?
First of all, can I tell you?
Yeah, tell me whatever you want.
Like you said,
that's not what we're talking about today.
I wanted to clarify what
we were talking about.
Oh yeah, do that.
No, no, I wanted to clarify
what we're talking about
when we say Jason Momoa
because people may not understand
what we're talking about,
but we'll come back to that in a second
because we are gonna talk
a little bit about that.
But the main thing we're
gonna talk about, go ahead.
Is this gift that you gave her
that has nothing to do with that,
that I had very little, you
know, I made an appearance.
You did,
you made a Cameo.
But, like I said,
this gift,
it's not that it wasn't the
most specific gift for Jessie
that you could give her,
but it's just so enjoyable for everybody.
It was so enjoyable for me,
it was such an experience,
I'm talking over an hour,
it was like the best movie
that you've ever seen.
Wow.
It was kind of like, that
was the experience I had.
I think you might've.
I've never enjoyed a gift
given to somebody else
more than how much I enjoyed
that gift that you gave Jessie.
What about my 40th birthday party?
This was better.
No, no way.
No, okay.
No.
No way.
No, okay, it wasn't that good,
but it was pretty great.
I'm talking about a
specific gift, not a party.
A singular gift.
My gift to Jessie, my
gifts to Jessie were done
considering the fact
that she could not have an
actual 40th birthday party.
Now, Jessie went out of her way
to plan my 40th birthday party,
all the details for why my party was great
are because of Jessie
and she loves parties, she loves people,
she loves planning stuff like that.
And, for years.
Great party.
Because I'm older
than she is,
I'm three years older than she is,
so for the past three years,
we've been talking about how
her 40th birthday party's
gotta be even better
than my 40th birthday party.
But, of course, it's not my fault
she decided to turn 40 in 2020, you know,
'cause she turned 40
right at the end of 2020.
COVID really crapped that up.
And there was all this conjecture
about whether or not, you know,
you remember at the
beginning of the pandemic
when we didn't know what
it was gonna be like
at the end of the year?
Well, it turns out
in LA it's gonna be as bad
as it could possibly get
at the end of the year, right?
The worst that it's been.
The worst that it's been,
it's continuing to get worse
as we're recording this.
However, what that meant
is that she couldn't have
the party that she wanted
and we talked about,
next year we'll do a whole
delayed gratification party,
which will be one hell of a
thing that happens for people.
There's gonna be lots of
people who had weddings,
birthday parties, and
things that they postponed.
The party business,
if you wanna invest in the
party business in late 2021,
that's what you should be investing in.
Let's buy a Party City.
Okay.
Every time I go into Party City,
I'm like, boy, I love being in here.
If Party City can make it.
I'm being facetious by the way.
Party City would be a great investment.
But, anyway,
that's what motivated me to
do both the Jason Momoa thing
and the thing we'll talk about,
and a couple of other things.
But, if you don't know
what we're talking about,
if you're listening to this on.
Monday
The day that it comes out.
Two days ago.
Two days ago
we did a vlog on the Rhett
and Link channel, Link,
ha ha vlogs!
That's right,
but we wanna say that
this is not a harbinger
of a lot more vlogs.
It's just, you wanted to
do this thing for Jessie,
it was an irresistible idea
to document for a vlog.
Yeah.
So we're like,
that's what we're gonna do,
if there's something that
we wanna turn into a vlog,
we're gonna do it.
Yeah, so we're not making a commitment
to say vlogs are back,
what we're just saying is.
We're demonstrating that
they can pop up.
Vlogs are a thing,
as we are inspired and as
we have something to film,
the vlog channel is not
dead, that's all we'll say,
but it is not going to be a weekly thing.
But we hope that you
enjoyed what we gave you,
and what I gave my wife.
It's a little
unscheduled treat zone.
And I will say, I wanna
put this idea out there,
I know we talked a little bit about it
during the making of the Jason Momoa vlog,
you can go watch it after this,
or you could pause it and
go watch it right now.
But, anyway, my wife is
really into Jason Momoa
and it's kind of like a running joke
and also as my hair has grown out,
I wouldn't say that I
look like Jason Momoa,
but I look more like Jason Momoa
than I did before I grew my hair out,
just because he also has
long hair and a beard.
So there's been this running joke
that I'm trying to be
Jason Momoa to my wife
and so we decided to go all the way,
and make this picture book
where I recreated these
epic Jason Momoa shots,
which didn't necessarily turn out epic
and I kind of regret putting
myself side by side with him
in the book,
but that is where the
most comedy comes from.
Yeah.
Now, but what's her
relationship with this book?
You said you don't even
know where it is it anymore?
Well, a couple of pages have
fallen out because of drool.
Oh God.
First of all, that's a
self-deprecating joke,
just so you know.
I'd never assume that.
I'm assuming she's drooling over Momoa.
But she has books that are
just him that she drools over.
No, she doesn't, actually, she doesn't.
Listen, I know she has a coloring book.
Yeah, because it was a
gift from your wife, right?
Yeah and the thing that
Christy was asserting
that she inspired.
She did.
This whole idea,
this is your opportunity
to give her some credit.
Christy showed me the
coloring book of Jason Momoa,
which was a lot like the coloring book,
"The Mythical Coloring Book",
like an adult coloring book
but it was not us, it was Jason Momoa.
And she was like
you should make a coloring
book of yourself as Jason Momoa
and I was like, that's a really good idea,
that's a very difficult thing to do,
but you know what I probably could do
is I could recreate some
of his actual photos.
So yeah, the idea came
from Christy's suggestion
to do a coloring book.
But she bought Jessie the coloring book,
so she does own the Jason
Momoa coloring book.
Yeah, yeah she does.
But where's the book you
made, you really don't know?
It's on her bedside table.
Seriously, what is the
lasting response to it?
Because you see her in the video,
you just get her initial
reaction from the vlog,
she's really getting a kick out of it,
it is very funny how you
put the lines in between it,
she loved it.
The fact that we made it into a video,
what she said was, "Oh, I see,
you're saying this is a gift for me?"
Oh.
"You just wanted to make a video."
Then she'll follow it up and say,
oh no, I'm kidding, it's
great, I like it, I love it,
I'm so glad you did it.
But, I mean, first of all,
we don't have it nearly as
bad as a family vlogger.
Oh gosh.
Could you imagine that?
'Cause then at every point,
everything that you're doing,
there's these split allegiances
between the person you're
doing it for and the audience,
I couldn't imagine living
like that, first of all.
Yeah.
'Cause having just done it
the few times that we've done it
and, in this case, very directly,
I got really excited about the idea
and I knew I could get you
excited about the idea.
Not to say, you're a great friend,
but there is no way in hell
you would have done that
without it being a video for
the Rhett and Link channel.
That's an interesting question.
'Cause you would have been like,
I mean, man, like,
really, we gotta do this?
Do you need me to do this?
I'm saying that
as someone who probably would
do the same thing to you,
I would try to talk you
into something else, right?
But the fact that we
knew it could be a video,
you're like, all right, I'll do it
and I'll kind of adopt
a little bit of a perspective in the video
that I'm really not into this,
which I really think worked.
I didn't know how else to play it.
I know, I think you played it right.
For me, the bigger question is,
no, so to answer your question,
she was very appreciative.
She was more appreciative
of the thing that we're gonna
talk about after the break,
I will say that.
As she should be.
Because it actually took more work
and it was just for her,
now, we aren't talking
about it on "Ear Biscuits",
you can't experience it
for reasons that we'll get into.
But the question I wanna answer
before we move on, or ask,
is, as we established,
this is an SAT question,
Jason Momoa is to Jessie
as blank is to Christy
and the answer is Keith Urban.
Listen, you can't walk this back now, man
'cause she's said this many times.
It's been a running joke for years.
But it started in reality.
No, I think it started
when you might say that you
have a crush on Keith Urban
and people might just
be like, oh I get it,
which would have been.
A long time ago.
Over a decade ago.
So it's a running joke
that has continued to run
from that amount of time,
I really don't think
that she's pulling up
images of Keith Urban.
Young Keith Urban, whatever you wanna say
at some point, she's still
into it, I would assume,
she hasn't changed her biological
responses to Keith Urban,
to just raw Keith Urban.
So, my question is.
Wrong Keith Urban.
Is that, you know,
I think that you look
as much like Keith Urban
as I look like Jason Momoa,
you know what I'm saying?
We could easily get your
hair to look like his hair,
he's clean shaven, you
know what I'm saying?
I think he still has.
Highlights.
We can do that.
By the way, I still think he's stuck
in the phase from over a decade ago
where people would get it,
he hasn't tried to change.
The question is, and I'm
telling you right now.
I don't get it by the way
and I don't get Nicole Kidman,
I don't get them as a couple.
You don't get who?
What do you mean you don't get it?
You don't get what people
see in Keith Urban?
Yeah.
Well, I guess, I don't personally see it,
but I think I can understand,
I think I can look at him
and tell that like, okay,
I could see that people
would find him attractive.
You want me to do a book?
That's the question,
I'm willing to play the
role that you played for me.
She's already turned 40.
Well, whatever she turns next,
can we do Link becomes Keith Urban?
And listen, because it's the second video,
we'll have to do something even bigger.
How do you know I haven't
already done that in private?
done it the right way?
Well, listen, I also know
that your dad got a Keith Urban
electric guitar for himself.
This is years ago, I
went to my dad's house,
this was for Christmas years ago,
and he had a guitar,
I've never seen or heard of
my dad playing an instrument
and I was like, you got a guitar,
he was like, yeah, they were
selling this Keith Urban
learn to play guitar online,
it was a cheap Keith Urban guitar
complete with the lessons.
The cheap, fill in the blank
celebrity guitar, right.
I'm pretty confident that
he's never played it.
So, I don't know, between me and my dad,
we both got some Keith Urban connections,
we both could make that happen.
Christy's birthday's in the spring, right?
It's in May.
Well we gotta get on, we
gotta start working on this,
yeah, start thinking about this.
May 13th, I do know the date.
So anyway, what I'm saying,
it's up to you if you wanna do it
but if you want to do it,
if you wanna pull the Keith Urban trigger,
if you wanna pull the Urban trigger
just know that I'm there
to hold the barrel.
I mean, that's probably not
the best analogy.
No, no, no.
I will support you and
take pictures of you.
All right, so I can't wait
to get into this thing,
but I have to get you to
share the pizza ordering story
that you told me over the break,
it's the one thing from the break
that I feel like we
need to fill in the gap
and I need you to tell
me that story as well.
Before the break?
After the break.
Oh, teaser.
Okay, you know what we've done?
Not anytime recently, but years ago,
we've set aside a whole
section of amazon.com.
I didn't know what you were gonna say.
And we call it amazon.com/mythical
and it's a place that you can go
if you're just like, I gotta
have that Prime shipping,
I don't wanna wait,
I want things as soon as
I possibly can get them,
well, the way to do that
is amazon.com/mythical.
Now, it's a different selection,
it's not the same stuff that
you get at mythical.com.
That's right.
It's different, it's a
whole different collection.
Equally mythical, succinctly separate.
Yeah.
Amazon.com/mythical.
Rep your boys over there.
Compare it to what you
would find at mythical.com.
Okay.
So I wanna get to the gift,
but when we were on our break
and we were separate from each other,
we did have this conversation,
you just couldn't wait
to tell me this story.
But just 'cause you told me,
first of all, I wanna hear it again
and I want them to hear it
because, beside the gift
that we're about to get into.
It's the best story from the break.
This is the other bright
spot from the break
'cause the break, just to
be official about this,
the break was really laying low
with the COVID of it all in
LA and not going back home,
just laying low.
I know that you do not
come to "Ear Biscuits"
or "Good Mythical
Morning", or anything else,
to hear more talk about the pandemic,
I get it, we're all
tired of hearing about it
but I do wanna talk just
to give you some context
about what's happening in Los Angeles
as we record this, right?
The situation is so dire
in Los Angeles right now
that if you have to go to the hospital
for any particular reason, COVID included,
the chances of you actually
not getting treated,
not getting into a hospital
bed are pretty high, right.
Ambulances are circling.
Circuling.
Circling the hospitals
and people are dying of
different conditions,
COVID included,
while they're waiting
to get into a hospital.
And so there's this incredible sense that,
I mean, I told my kids, I was like, guys,
don't do anything stupid.
First of all,
we're already doing
all the COVID protocols
and not going out.
If you break a leg.
I'm like, if you break a leg,
I'm gonna put you in a splint,
I got a broom and some duct tape
because they said do not
go to the emergency room
unless it's a life or death situation
and I know the situation
is dire in other places
but Los Angeles
has become the epicenter of
the pandemic at this point
for a number of factors
that we won't go into.
But, ultimately, it's a really
really scary time, locally
and anybody who has said it's just the flu
or, you know what, it's
not really that serious,
it's just a cold,
colds and flus do not
overwhelm the hospital system
in the way that COVID has.
Even if there's a high chance
that you're gonna survive this thing,
the net effect on a population
of people experiencing COVID
is that it overwhelms the medical staff
and the facilities in the
way that it is right now.
And so that's why, in Los Angeles,
in order to not contribute
further to the problem,
we're doing everything
we can to remain safe.
And to laugh instead of crying.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Keep from crying,
and that's what this story means to me.
So, again, earlier, even
just two months ago,
I might take a trip into the grocery store
to pick something up,
or if I needed to go quickly buy something
at the hardware store, I would
mask up and go in, right,
but, in Los Angeles, there's
been all these outbreaks
at retail and grocery stores.
We've clamped back down.
30 people at so-and-so,
at the Ralph's are suddenly
infected, or whatever,
so we're doing all delivery,
we're not going out.
However, there was a time over the break
where we ordered pizza,
we were trying to order
pizza from this place
and we couldn't get them on the phone.
And so I was like, all
right, you know what?
I need to get out, I'm
just gonna drive down there
and I'm gonna order the
pizza in person or whatever.
And I go to this place and I look,
and I see that they've got
a socially distanced line
for people to order
pizza, but it's inside.
And so there's probably
like, I don't know,
maybe a total of 10
people inside this place,
including the staff behind the counter
and the people in line.
Listen, we've been super locked down
so I'm not comfortable doing
this, but you know what?
I got my mask on, everybody
else has got their mask on,
it's a limited amount of
time, I'm gonna go in,
but I was feeling uncomfortable
like I was taking a risk, right?
So I go inside this
place and I get in line
and I'm in there for five minutes or so
and move a couple of spaces.
And then I see there's a couple of girls
who have just ordered their
pizza and are walking out,
and they see me and they recognize me,
and they say oh, hey,
we were actually just watching
you yesterday or whatever,
I was like, oh great
to meet you, whatever.
Now, oftentimes when
this happens in public,
if you get recognized in public,
people who do not know who you are
feel that it is their
absolute moral obligation
to then ask you who you are,
it is one of my pet peeves,
it is one of my least
favorite things in the world
but hey, listen,
if it means that things
are going well for us.
If that's what you're complaining about,
then you're life's pretty good.
It's a privileged problem,
but it's just a pet peeve,
that's all I'm saying.
So two girls and a guy,
approximately 20 years old,
one of them behind me says,
"Excuse me, sir, who are you?"
I'm like, here we go, here we go.
And I'm sorry, I'm usually pretty nice,
almost always pretty nice.
You're on edge.
When this question is asked
and I'm also thinking
about the fact that I'm not
comfortable being in here,
I said,
I smiled but you couldn't tell
because I've got my mask on,
"If you don't know, you won't care."
Because, is that not true?
It's true.
Is me saying, well,
I have a YouTube channel
that's pretty popular
and that's where those girls knew me from,
how is that going to
change this person's life?
You know what I'm saying?
I know, she's just curious.
But it's also an opportunity
for somebody to say they
met somebody famous,
even if they didn't know who it was.
I get it.
However, the only thing
that I can think of,
as I'm saying, "If you
don't know you won't care",
is that the young man who
was with these two girls.
Still in his 20s?
Yeah.
Not a boy, a man.
Does not have on a mask.
Now, call me what you will,
you know what I'm saying,
I know there's people who
listen to this podcast
who think that masks don't matter
and that COVID's not a big deal,
this story is just gonna piss
you off, I'm cool with that.
But what I said was, "Hey
bro, where's your mask?".
Oo, you did it, you
went there, didn't you?
Was it calculated or was
it a knee jerk reaction?
I wasn't even thinking about it,
I was just like, this guy
doesn't have a mask on
and the only thing I'm thinking about
is the fact that I'm not
comfortable being in here
because COVID, basically,
is exposure level versus times time,
that's how you calculate your risk level,
and exposure level goes up
when someone doesn't have a
mask on, if they have it, right.
This catches him off guard
and then the girl with him is like,
well, it's in the car, you
really should go get your mask
and I was like, you really should.
Ah!
And I said, "You should
either put on a mask,
or you should leave."
And he was like, whoa this
guy's really laying it down,
and I was like, yeah,
this is serious, man,
it's a serious thing, it's
not hard to put on a mask.
And then that was when he was like.
His girlfriend had on a mask.
He was like, oh, you're from YouTube.
Well, I actually just messed
the story up a little bit,
because after I said, "You
should put on a mask",
or after I said, "Where's your mask?",
they said it's in the
car, then he recognized me
and said, "Oh, YouTube!".
And I was like, yeah,
and I was like, you should put on a mask
or you should leave,
and that was when he got
really uncomfortable,
and I just turned back around.
You gave him the back?
I turned back around to keep going in line
and also to turn away from him,
and that was when he said, "Unsubscribe!".
I still can't believe he said that.
He unsubscribed in public, out loud,
vocally, verbally.
I gotta give him respect
because you criticize people
for saying things in comments
that they would never say out loud,
but I never thought that that,
which you see frequently in comments,
would be something that anyone
would ever say out loud.
No, I actually appreciate it.
Unsubscribe.
Like I said.
He just unsubscribed verbally,
do you have to do the work then?
I don't know.
To find his account.
I don't know if he then
brings up his account
and unsubscribes,
however, like I said, I wasn't mad,
I mean, there was a part of me
that was like if this guy
really wants to roll with me about this,
what am I gonna do?
Because, by this point,
everyone in the restaurant
was listening to our conversation,
'cause no one's talking,
everybody's quiet.
And so as soon as I said,
"Bro, where's your mask?",
it was like a pin drop kind of moment
and people were like, oh, this
dude's calling this guy out
in front of everybody.
And he was not a small guy and
it's not like I'm a fighter,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm a big guy, but the
last time I fought somebody
was John Carson in third grade.
Big or small, one subscriber
is just one subscriber.
However, he then leaves.
Oh, he did?
He did, he left and he
came back with a mask on,
and he was like, I've got the mask on.
And I said, "Hey, I
really appreciate that,
thanks for doing that."
And then that's when he says.
Resubscribe?
No, no, no, no,
he said, "Mythical Kitchen."
What?
He made the connection, or?
It wasn't like he's a fan,
it was like, I've seen you on YouTube.
But then his point of reference was,
after he went back, put the
mask on, thought about it,
Mythical Kitchen
and I was just like, yep,
I'm not gonna be like, well,
"Good Mythical Morning",
'cause it's technically true,
I have appeared on Mythical Kitchen.
So anyway.
Wow, unsubscribe.
I really appreciate,
listen, he has every right to unsubscribe
and you have every right
to unsubscribe to this
if you don't like my
opinion about this stuff.
But if I find you in a
public place without a mask,
I'm going to talk to you about it,
that's just what I'm gonna do,
especially in Los Angeles,
this is serious, man.
I wonder how many YouTube
professionals, as we are,
have experienced being
unsubscribed to verbally,
it can't be that many, that's great.
You think it might be the first time ever?
No.
No, it's happened.
I'm sure it's happened.
But just to say that publicly,
he didn't even, at that point,
he didn't even know what
channel, as he proved later.
Yeah, yeah, right.
If he unsubscribes from Mythical
Kitchen because of this,
I'm sorry, Josh, what can I tell you?
Unsubscribe.
I like it, it's succinct,
it goes to the core of your.
It was very quick thinking on his part.
Your wellbeing, your livelihood.
All right, but let's
get into this gift, man,
okay, set up what you did.
Okay, so, again, Jessie
couldn't have a party,
so I was thinking, how do I
get all the people who love her
and would, otherwise,
maybe come to a party
to show their appreciation for her?
Now, the general idea isn't
particularly creative,
a lot of people have done this,
you make a compilation video
featuring family and friends
saying something that they
appreciate about Jessie.
And so I was like, I
definitely am gonna do that,
but I was like, I don't
wanna just do the same thing
that everyone else does,
which is just get people just
to make a compilation video.
It's sweet, it's nice, maybe she'll cry,
maybe she'll laugh,
but how do I take this to the next level?
Now, I'm sure you've heard
about the service, Cameo,
which is, essentially,
a service where you
pay to have a celebrity
make a custom video for you
and it varies in price,
some people might be $25,
I think Snoop Dogg is $900.
But you can, basically,
if you wanna get Snoop Dogg
to wish your cousin a happy birthday
or happy graduation,
or give them an encouraging
word or whatever, you can pay.
And it's an app, right?
It's a website, I think
there's also an app.
So they're all listed on there.
And you can search, basically,
by different categories of celebrity.
There's a few YouTubers on there
but it tends to be
mostly, what I would say,
we're not talking A-listers,
you cannot get Brad
Pitt to deliver a Cameo
because Brad Pitt's time is
probably more valuable spent
doing whatever else Brad Pitt does
rather than making videos for people.
It's interesting,
Snoop Dogg is the only exception,
I wouldn't call him an A-list celebrity,
but I wouldn't call him
anything lower either,
he's in his own parallel
strata of celebrity,
he'll show up anywhere and everywhere.
Yeah.
But somehow, it legitimizes that thing,
it doesn't de-legitimize him.
And, who knows,
I don't know how Cameo works,
but, yes, Snoop gets
paid each time he does it
but he probably also
got a pretty sweet deal
just to go onto the service.
Yeah, maybe so, yeah.
You know, I'm assuming
that they pay people
who people would really demand,
I don't know how it works,
I don't know the inner workings of it.
All I know is that a lot
of the people on Cameo
are people who are known for things,
like there's a whole
reality TV section, right?
So you've got people
who have been on all
these reality TV shows,
who, you know,
they're trying to cash in
on their fame a little bit
and how easy is it to just sit down
and say I'm gonna record 10
happy birthday videos for people
over the course of an hour,
and make a few hundred bucks
or whatever it comes out to.
And I gotta think the COVID of it all,
with people being more locked
down with their hands tied,
they're not actively working as much,
you monetize that time,
the equation changes a little bit,
you might get people
who normally wouldn't
be on there, on there.
And even though you know how it works,
being that like, okay,
these people make themselves available
and they then get paid
to do a handful of these,
however many, depends on
how in demand they are.
I know that they just sat down
and read some facts off of
a screen and did a video,
and then they did another
video and then another video.
But despite knowing that's how it works,
it still comes across
as especially meaningful
for the person who receives the video,
especially if you don't know about Cameo.
I'd like to explore that in
the context of some specifics
because I do have some
observations about the experience
of that.
Okay.
But you have to set up how it happens.
So I had two general ideas, right,
I was like, I'm gonna make this video
that's got all her
family and friends in it
and then, without telling her,
I'm going to pepper in people that are.
Reality TV stars.
Meaningful to me and her,
or just I thought it would be
funny to have them involved.
And so, we'll talk about
who those people are
and where they're from,
but the thing that I also did,
there's a section
where you can write some
personal information
about the person who's getting a Cameo
and I was like, how can
I make this even more fun
than it's already gonna be?
Well, I'm gonna make up a
bunch of stuff about Jessie
that's not true.
Like, for instance, I'm going
to say that she's turning 40
and she also has 40 tattoos,
I'm going to say that
she is an avid juggler,
she's an avid fisher woman,
she is a mountain climber
who has climbed the following mountains
and whose dream is to climb Everest.
She grew up working on a pig farm
and also, every birthday, she
bakes herself a 12 layer cake.
Now, Jessie hates baking,
she likes cooking somewhat, hates baking
'cause she doesn't really
like being told what to do
or follow directions,
so baking is not for
those kinds of people.
And so it was the the irony
of saying that she makes a 12 layer cake,
it was a little joke between us.
So I put this information out there
and then reached out
to all the people who
were significant to us,
and a fair number of them, if
not all of them, responded.
The first person I remember.
Well, you wanna get the
context for why you were there
when I showed it?
Yes, I forgot that.
So, to celebrate Jessie's birthday,
we went away, we got an
Airbnb outside of Joshua Tree,
just the four of us,
having already been a pod,
when you take the whole COVID
stuff into consideration,
given how much we have to work together
it's right on the heels of
us working together anyway,
it was a safe decision for
the four of us to be together.
And so we're hanging out that
night and she didn't know it,
Christy gave her her birthday present
and, after that, you break out the laptop
and you're like I have a
birthday present for you as well,
and, of course, Christy
and I knew what it was
because we contributed
to it as loved ones.
And Jessie kinda knows at this point,
oh, he's made a video.
Right.
And Christy's like,
well, Rhett, should we be here for this?
Isn't this something
that's just for Jessie?
Because people say
really meaningful things
that could be private
for her, I don't know,
they didn't necessarily think
that we were gonna be watching this.
And you were like, no, no,
no, I put this thing together,
and, of course, I knew
about the Cameo part
'cause you told me, I
don't think Christy knew,
you're like, no, no, no, no,
this is perfect to be
watched with you guys.
So, it was, in retrospect,
I'm so grateful that
you created this thing
and, like I said,
I loved it, invited me and
Christy into the experience
of watching Jessie watch
it for the first time.
As I was editing it,
I knew all along that
you were gonna be there,
that you and Christy were gonna be there.
So, when Christy said that,
are you sure you want us to be here?
I was like, well, first of
all, where are you gonna go?
We're in this Airbnb in
the middle of the desert.
But anyway, so the video starts off
and I've got a little intro,
and then some of her friends,
and, actually,
the last person right
before the first celebrity
is your wife.
Now, we're not gonna play
any of these videos because.
I wish we could.
The funny thing is, is that.
I'm frustrated.
I'm assuming that those people
who made videos for Jessie
who also listen to "Ear Biscuits",
have probably been thinking,
up to this point,
is he gonna play that
video on "Ear Biscuits",
that I made privately for Jessie?
No, I'm not gonna do that,
I would never do that,
the only person who has seen
that is, of course, Jessie
and then Link and Christy,
but you cannot show a Cameo video.
Now, if you get a Cameo,
I sound like I'm making an ad for Cameo,
but if I got somebody to make
a video for Jessie on Cameo,
I could put it on my
personal social media,
she could put it on her
personal social media.
But because this podcast
is a commercial product, technically.
We make money off this podcast,
so we can't put it in there.
It's against
the terms of service,
I can't tell you or play
these videos for you.
But I don't think that's gonna
ruin the experience for you,
because we're gonna talk about
some of the things that people said
and explore the concept.
It is frustrating
that most people, when they get a Cameo,
you know that it's gonna
be shared on social media
amongst the circle of friends.
Yeah.
And you can tell
by the way that certain
people contributed,
they would add certain context
or promotional statements around it
because they know more people
besides this one person I'm talking to
are gonna see this,
so I might as well take
advantage to promote my project
or whatever.
Yeah, that happened a couple of times.
But as you'll see on this first one,
which the first person
to appear in the video
is Chris Harrison,
host of "The Bachelor"
and "The Bachelorette",
just, you know, "The Bachelor" enterprise,
the face of that whole thing.
As you can see,
I zoomed in past the watermark
that says Cameo on the bottom,
so that the first one that she saw,
she would just think
that I had personally reached
out to Chris Harrison.
That's the beauty of this,
especially if you can zoom past Cameo,
you make people think that
you've just arranged this
'cause Chris Harrison
basically says, hi Jessie,
your wonderful husband, Rhett,
wanted me to wish you
a happy 40th birthday.
He's a consummate professional.
Chris Harrison.
Is the best.
He's the best,
I think the only person.
One of the best.
The only person who might
do as good of a job at this
is Probst.
I think that Jeff Probst,
who's not on there.
Oh, he's gotta be on mine.
These guys just specialize
in being able to sit down
and just say something
that feels meaningful.
But the thing that Chris Harrison has
is he has a rose and he gives the rose,
will you accept this rose?
Or whatever.
I bet he didn't give that rose to anyone
right before that video
or in the next video he
made right after you.
He's also the most expensive
person on the list,
I don't wanna disclose the prices, but.
Well you said Snoop was $900.
Well, he's not as expensive as Snoop,
he's the most expensive person
that I personally contacted.
Okay.
So Chris Harrison was the first one
and, at this point,
because Chris Harrison.
First of all, anyone can go on Cameo,
they can see how much it costs.
Well, I don't know, I
think he's 500 bucks,
I just can't remember exactly everything.
Well, I'll tell you, it was worth it.
He was a consummate professional,
he made eye contact with the camera lens,
he seemed like he was
peering into Jessie's soul,
hell, my soul when I was watching.
He also connected to her,
given her juggling and her fishing,
which he said he enjoyed
both of those things.
And said we should all get
together and juggle and fish.
And he gave her the rose,
it was a great bit.
Other people have other bits.
Yeah.
That they'll go into.
Okay, so the next person who showed up
was James the jet ski
guy from "Tiger King".
And is he sitting in a
golf cart, holding a phone,
just kind of talking to her?
He's out in the open.
Possibly.
He's outside in Florida.
He's got his Aviators on,
it's like Cameo sent him an email,
somebody wants to pay you to talk to 'em,
he's like, oh, let me get on it right now
in my golf cart.
I think he might be relatively,
so some of the people on the
site have put their past work
and you can see what they
say and how they do it,
I think he's pretty in demand.
He's hilarious.
The reason I wanted,
first of all, because we watched
"Tiger King" and loved it,
the thing that I love about him,
is at the end of his Cameo,
and my impression based on the other.
He was impressed with her tattoos.
Of course, he latched
onto the tattoo thing.
With the Aviators on,
you really can't tell that
he's reading some notes,
but you can tell he's like, what,
it's like he's reacting to the notes,
he's like, oh damn, 40 tattoos, man.
And what did he say?
He was like, I gotta
give you credit for that.
It was like someone was
whispering in his ear.
He invited her down to Florida
to ride jet skis with him,
he did that
and then the last thing he did,
he said, "You know that
bitch, Carole Baskin?
I think she definitely
killed her husband."
That's his closing.
That's his closing,
he also says check out
season two of "Tiger King"
coming soon,
which I didn't even know was a thing,
but, again, promotion.
You found out.
Yeah.
And now we're telling everybody
that there's a season two.
But, of course, I followed up James,
right after he said,
"That bitch Carole Baskin
killed her husband",
I followed up with Carole Baskin.
Yes.
And she says, "Hello all
you cats and kittens",
or whatever she says,
and then proceeds to talk to Jessie.
'Cause some people
are so entrenched in their catchphrases,
they really can't get out of the fact
that they're talking to
one person right now.
Right.
She's a vlogger in her
own right, of sorts,
so she has her vlogging
catchphrases like that.
But the thing I remember about Carole
is that it got very candid.
Very personal.
She would take some of the notes,
like she really enjoyed the
factoid about the 12 layer cake,
"I understand that every birthday
you make a 12 layer, 12
layers, that's a lot.
I would really love for you
to send me one of those,
I would love to sink my teeth into that."
And then she's like, "But
actually, you know what?
Don't send me a cake
because I can't eat
anything people send me,
because there's people who say
they're trying to kill me."
You can kind of tell.
This is all top of mind.
She's looking off a little
bit, it's top of mind,
she's verbally processing
her own situation,
it's very self-deprecating,
it's very endearing
and connecting,
but it's like she really
gave of herself to Jessie,
you know?
She was like, "You know what?
I would love to get cake from you,
but I can't because people
are trying to kill me."
Right, yeah.
I never expected it and it
happened to a number of people
where it's like they were
able to tap into a sincerity,
I'm doing this video, I might
as well be a real person
and then there're more than glimpses
of people actually being
themselves conversationally.
Yeah.
And you know what?
It's not an easy thing to do
because, as you look through all of us
who aren't celebrities on Cameo,
who made these videos for Jessie,
just the act of doing it,
there's a risk and you gotta
check a lot of your insecurity
when you're not someone who's
used to staring into a camera
and making a video.
Well, even when you are someone
who's used to staring into a camera.
Okay, I see you pulled
me up here, I'm edgy.
Right after Carole Baskin,
Link Neal, and you know what?
I didn't even have to pay Link Neal.
Yeah, what's up with that?
Link Neal is not on Cameo.
I should have created a Cameo,
I could have got a little scratch.
Do you want me to play this for us?
Because this is the one
that you have the permission to release.
No.
Okay, all right, I'll
respect your privacy.
I don't care, play it.
Okay.
Jessie, happy birthday.
I wanna wish you all the
good cheer and tidings.
Okay, I'm gonna get serious this time,
I really want you to
have a happy birthday,
listen, this quarantine thing
it sucks, you know what?
I don't wanna talk
about anything negative,
I want this all to be positive.
I'm gonna stop/start.
Seriously Jessie,
I just wanna wish you a happy birthday
and let you know that
I value our friendship,
and it's an interesting friendship,
to be friends because you're
married to my best friend,
it's almost like we're
brother and sister-in-law,
or something,
so, love you like a
sister, happy birthday.
Listen, listen.
That was sweet, that was good.
I really wanted to say something honest
but then it's like, man,
why is this so awkward?
Even the thing I made at the beginning.
It's a tough thing.
Which was basically
just like, hey baby, whatever, you know.
Like I can talk to all y'all,
but when you're talking to one person
and then I know that
you're gonna watch it,
and it's like ugh!
It was just a weird confluence.
And you know what?
It caught me at an interesting time, okay.
Yeah.
It was late, obviously, I
didn't have myself together,
look at me, I'm a wreck.
It's great, it's great.
There's a whole story there
that I'm not even gonna go into.
Just because I sense how
it could be frustrating,
I'm gonna just rush through a
few other ones that I included
and tell you why I did.
So, the trashiest show
we've ever watched together,
my wife and I have ever watched together,
"Too Hot To Handle" on Netflix,
where people basically got
together at this resort
and you got penalized for having sex,
and it was all these hot people
who wanted to have sex with each other.
Okay.
And Francesca from that show
who is just a very distinct personality
and I knew Jessie would immediately,
basically it was like,
when you see Francesca
give a happy birthday message to Jessie,
what it communicates to Jessie
is I remember we sat down and
we watched this show together
and just were horrified
by the people on it,
but, hey, here's one of them
wishing you happy birthday,
so it was a sort of a point of connection.
Then, okay,
so I did a whole episode of "Ear Biscuits"
where I talked about our
obsession with "90 Day Fiancé",
how Jessie and I just watched this thing
and just couldn't get enough of it.
And I told you about this guy, David,
who I think is from Las Vegas
and he was the one that had this,
what seemed to be an absolute delusion,
about this woman in Russia
that he was chatting with,
not even video chatting with,
just text chatting with, for years.
And he would go to Russia multiple times,
and every time he went to Russia,
she would come up with an excuse
why she couldn't meet him,
and, of course, everyone watching
knew the excuse was
because she doesn't exist.
However, biggest spoiler alert
if you're gonna watch
that season with David
of "90 Day Fiancé", fast
forward through this.
But Lana did exist
and the seventh time he went
to Russia, he actually met her,
so I had to include
David in the compilation.
Now, one thing I'll say about David is,
I don't know if this is
because David hasn't gotten
a multitude of requests
or if he just really invests a lot of time
into each one that he receives.
He seemed to have a lot
of time on his hands.
He went for 10 minutes
and I did not include his full 10 minutes
in the compilation,
I took about a minute or two
and then we watched an extended
cut later in the night.
But he had a whole bit where
he was blowing up balloons
and talking a lot about his
experience with marriage
and love, and that kind of thing,
which was very insightful.
And then it was followed up by
none other than Lana herself,
yes, she's also on Cameo.
Oh my gosh.
So you can do the David
and Lana one-two punch.
And she also, again,
maybe for similar reasons,
went for about 10 minutes.
She seemed to have a script.
She was reading a very long script.
She was reading a speech,
it was like a political speech almost.
No, it was inspirational,
it was very inspirational.
It was inspirational, yeah.
It's very inspirational.
And catered towards Jessie.
So you get the idea of the novelty of it
and you're like, okay, you
get a kick out of this,
but the thing that I didn't anticipate
was that there's an extremely powerful
overriding element here
and that's when they look at you
and say your name, and include
details, falsified details,
about your life, growing up on a pig farm.
And by the way, I wanna say
I don't know if I personally
violated the terms of service
by giving false information,
but clearly that can't be,
you can make a joke out
of it if you want to.
But it doesn't, even though you know
how ridiculous and novel
this whole thing is
and how fun it is,
the humanity of the exercise trumps it all
and you find yourself
actually feeling something.
And not even the moments
where people are being surprisingly real,
but just the fact that
they're talking to you,
there's a magical engagement
when somebody who you've
watched on television
says your name and starts talking to you
and there's a magic in Cameo
that I never thought
I would be describing.
Well, I did include real
details, my name, her name,
our kids' names, our kids' ages,
our height difference,
and stuff like that that's true,
how long we've been together, how we met,
all that stuff I included,
so they would talk about that as well
'cause I didn't want
it just to be all fake,
I just wanted some of the details be fake.
So then we get into the
section of the video
where I start peppering in some people
that are just there for
my own personal enjoyment,
but I know that she will get
a kick out of it as well,
because I could only find so many people
who had been on shows
that we watched together.
Yeah.
So, again, I'm a child of the '80s
and was in high school in the '90s,
so I know who Kato Kaelin is.
Kato Kaelin is the guy who was
the first person on the scene
after the OJ murder,
who was in court and he had this hair,
and he was this typical Californian dude.
Well, he's gone on to, I don't know what,
he's just continued to be Kato Kaelin
and he wrote a song for Jessie,
he wrote a custom song that
rhymes my name with things
and her name.
It was bad.
It wasn't a great song.
I think he knew it was bad
and that was part of it.
Yeah, right, so I appreciated that.
And then just because my wife is really,
she is very into the news,
can I just say that,
she's very into the news.
Okay.
And so people who have been in the news
over the past few years, for
political reasons or otherwise,
she's probably gonna be familiar with them
and whatever reason, Michael Cohen,
Donald Trump's former personal lawyer
who is basically no longer his lawyer
and now a very big vocal
critic of the president.
What was he sentenced to?
Was he sentenced to anything?
I don't know if he.
He's at home in the
video, he's not in prison.
I actually, I don't know,
I don't know what his legal
situation is at this time,
but I will say he had one of the best
and most encouraging speeches,
and it was also very personal
and he was just talking about
how long he'd been married,
I'm not saying he didn't
also tell this story
to the next Cameo he did, but it was good
and Jessie was like, wow, that was sweet.
It was strange to see Michael Cohen,
I mean, I remember the hearings,
the Senate hearings,
where he was testifying
and then all of a sudden
he's talking to Jessie
and he's having the most down to earth
one sided conversation.
That's the beauty of the service, man.
This is not an ad for a Cameo, by the way,
just so you know.
I would do one
because I think there's
no other service like it,
as far as I know, and
it worked well for me,
but this is just an honest testimonial.
You got this, the next guy
I had heard was on Cameo
and that he was,
a year ago, when it started,
people started talking about
it, or whenever that was,
Gilbert Gottfried's name came up.
Yeah.
And here you go, you got him.
I mean, of course you got to.
If Gilbert Gottfried is on there,
you gotta to use him, right?
He really went with the whole
Jessie grew up on a pig farm thing,
that was his whole angle.
And he used it as a way to question
if I was trying to insult her,
'cause what I said was, in my information,
I said, "Jessie grew up on a pig farm
and everyone makes fun of her for it."
So he kind of leaned into that and said,
"I can't believe that your
husband is calling you a pig."
And then he was like,
but if you are a pig.
Yeah, it was kind of like
a scathing stand-up comic routine.
It was performance art,
it was performance art.
It was like reverse heckling.
But I actually thought he
was calling your bluff,
that obviously you made this up,
I thought that was part of it.
He probably knows that people do that.
I think he's been doing it the longest.
To know that people make stuff up.
You can tell that he's
reading and he doesn't care,
but then he riffs on things
that make it really funny.
I'm not gonna play this one,
but I will say that Stevie and Cassie
had a very produced angle,
what I mean is they had a
bit that they were doing
and I think it really turned out.
Yeah, that was good.
That was one of the high
points in the video,
so thank you to Stevie and Cassie.
I didn't know who these women were.
Then there were some twins,
you might remember the twins,
I actually don't remember their names
but they were from "90
Day Fiancé" as well.
They're the twins from Connecticut
who I think they're
getting their own show,
they're getting their own reality show
because they say that in this Cameo.
So again, it's working,
the twins from Connecticut
are getting their own reality show.
I didn't like them, they
didn't really connect with me.
It felt a little canned
just because they talked about
how much they loved Jessie.
It felt like an Instagram story.
They don't know Jessie,
how do they know that they love her?
Another guy, Ash, who
was from "90 Day Fiancé"
who's in Australia,
who was a a relationship coach
who seemed to only coach women,
which was an interesting thing about him.
And then we had, of course,
everybody's favorite TV show host,
aside from Chris Harrison and
Jeff Probst, Mark Summers,
host of "Double Dare"
and here's the thing about Mark Summers
that was really funny.
Yeah.
Again, for the reasons
that you talked about,
because these things go out to people.
He had a whole preamble.
His preamble was "I'm Mark Summers,
you may remember me from Double Dare,
I also did some time with",
and then he talks about the
show he did on the Food Network,
and then he talks about the fact
that he's an executive producer
on "Guy's Grocery Games".
He basically puts all his,
anything that he would talk
about at the end of a PR spot,
he puts at the top of his
Cameo, which is smart.
Yeah.
He really grasped hold
of the mountain climbing
and talked about how she
must be in incredible shape
if she's doing all this mountain climbing.
I think he ended with
saying something like,
good luck with those peaks.
Yeah, I kind of started
to feel for these people
who are regurgitating your lies.
Yeah, I felt bad about that as well
but it was also worth the laughs.
And then we come to it.
This is, okay,
first of all, if there are any children
listening to this particular
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
and you're not comfortable
with explicit talk of sexual acts,
probably have them leave
because we're gonna talk about this one
I just did for myself and
for the juggalos out there,
Violent J of the Insane Clown Posse
and I was like, I gotta use this guy,
and he went for, also,
10 minutes approximately.
Insane Clown Posse.
Yeah.
I had an idea,
I mean, they dress up like
these insane looking clowns
and I didn't understand the type of music,
even though I'd watched the documentary,
the Gathering of the Juggalos,
you got all these people who camp out,
this whole community around them,
it's super fascinating and super specific,
they're not metal, I
get them confused with.
Slipknot.
They're nothing like Slipknot.
Slipknot is like scary Marilyn Manson,
grotesque, shock rock.
And there's also
nine members of Slipknot.
And they wear masks.
Insane Clown Posse
is basically just the two dudes.
And they do bad '90s rap.
Yeah, a little bit like
House of Pain-sounding,
but not as good.
Not as good.
I don't know enough
to know what really
connects people to them
in the community,
but that's just like, if
you listen to one song,
you're like, what is going on here?
Now, Violent J took a very
specific angle in his video.
He was in full clown face.
Full clown face,
so he gets into character
and the character is, you know, insane,
let's just be honest,
I mean, that's the whole point, right?
So I did not include
the most explicit parts
in the main video,
because I didn't wanna distract
from all the good loving that
she was getting from people,
right?
Yeah.
As you said, the glad tidings and cheer,
or whatever you said.
So I basically just, I kept
the beginning of his video
where he just talked about me
and he talked about her, and
wishing her happy birthday,
and how old he was, and stuff like that,
he had a whole bit about how old he was.
It was nice,
but, again, after the fact, we
listened to his entire thing
and that was where, at some point, again,
I think most of this
was just off the cuff,
at some point,
Violent J decided that he
was going to talk about
his attraction to my wife.
Now, I don't even have
any reason to believe
that he's seen a picture of her
but I just think his angle was,
I'm going to turn this into
me hitting on the wife,
I know the husband made
this video for her,
but now I'm gonna talk about
what I'm going to do with his wife.
And the thing that really stuck with you
and Christy, and Jessie, and me,
as we watched this later that night,
was the fact that he said
he was going to do 69,
69 times with my wife.
Yeah, it's very catchy.
And, boy, that's a lot.
I wanna 69 you, 69 times.
Yeah, right.
I think is what he said, yeah.
I was like, hm, fascinating.
He said other things,
but that was really the peak
and that kind of captures the essence
of what he was getting at.
He also did some free styling.
Yeah, it was like this
off the top of the head
kind of scatting, but he did it,
it was like a character trait
where he would get manic and start.
Yeah.
Like a word association, like mouth vomit
of rhyming words.
That was a bit scary.
Now, I gotta say.
I loved it.
I didn't feel threatened,
my wife tells me that I'm very
secure in our relationship.
Meanwhile, he's making a flip book
of side by side pictures
of him and you, for her.
Well, here's the thing,
sometimes Jessie will come
back from some place in public
and she'll tell a story
about some dude that said
something to her, right.
And I know that some guys have a response
which is like, where is he?
I'm gonna go back there and
ask him what he's doing.
But I, typically, am
just like, good for you.
You can't even count to 69.
I'm like, that's awesome
to have somebody hit on you in that way,
it just reminds you that you still got it.
So when Violent J told my wife
that he wanted to do 69, 69 times
and, let me just say,
there was a couple of
times during that night,
as we kept repeating it,
that sometimes people
would say 69, 69 ways,
but I'm pretty sure he says 69, 69 times,
I think 69 is just,
that is the way.
That is the way.
To quote "The Mandalorian".
I'm sure you can do it other ways,
but, typically, it is
describing an action and an act.
This is the way.
And he just wants to do it 69 times,
and I was like, listen, Jessie,
if things ever get difficult,
if things get dark,
if you begin to doubt
that you still got it,
just remember that Violent J told you
that he wanted to 69, 69 times
and I don't know what 69 times 69 is,
I don't do that kind of math,
but it's a lot.
69 squared.
It's a lot.
Matter of fact, she don't
have to remember it,
she can just pull up the
video and watch it again.
We haven't watched it since,
well, maybe she's watched it on her own.
I think it should be a monthly thing,
I think on the 69th day of the year,
you should watch it 69 times.
Okay, that's gonna to take a while
'cause, like I said, he fully commits.
Sometime in March.
This is informative
for anybody who might be
thinking about doing a Cameo,
Violent J is gonna go all the way
and he's gonna go all the way,
literally, he's gonna give it.
I actually, have never
considered 69 going all the way.
Okay, well I think it might
been going past all the way,
maybe coming all the way back around.
Full circle.
Yeah.
Jaleel White, I got him to do it.
Did I do that?
He was so.
Did you do that?
Oh, he brought up another
fact that I added which was.
He was on a golf course.
I said in my false information
that Jessie had the
largest insect collection
west of the Mississippi River,
implying that there was a bigger one
east of the Mississippi River.
He really went with that and
actually told a personal story
about the time they had
a bug collector character
on "Family Matters",
and how she was really
attractive and made him nervous,
but then, after that episode,
he would get comments
about bug collecting,
Urkel was into bug collecting
because of this girl.
Just a little thing that
we could have never known,
we would've never known this
if I had told him the truth.
He was also very inspirational,
like, this day is the first
day of the rest of your life,
I don't know if he said that specifically.
Yeah.
It was that kind of inspirational talk.
Everybody had their approach.
Yeah.
And some people's approach
was I need to be a motivational speaker,
I need to say something positive
to help these people out.
But they have no credentials
or no business doing that,
kind of reminds me of this podcast.
It was kind of like a ray of light
that these people who find
themselves being listened to
are like, you know what?
I'm going to say something encouraging,
it's gonna be hollow.
and it's gonna be based on
something that I've read a second ago
or that I'm currently reading
just beside the camera,
but still, you gotta give
'em an A plus for effort.
It still means things.
There wasn't anybody who was like,
they weren't really trying.
Yeah.
Was there?
Was there anybody who
you wouldn't get again?
Well, this one, the one
I'm about to show you.
Oh yeah.
He was also, I think, the cheapest one,
the fly on Mike Pence's head.
If you remember the
vice-presidential debate
when a fly landed on Mike Pence's head,
well, I think this guy was
really trying to ride that wave,
which that wave has
crashed, at this point.
15 minutes of fame's up.
He has a fly mask on and a fly suit on.
Altered voice.
And an altered fly voice.
And he says a lot, quite a
few jokes, but you know what?
It was worth a little bit of a laugh.
And, actually, that was the last one.
I edited this thing last minute
and so I ended with the fly,
I probably should have put him in earlier
but, actually, he wasn't the last thing,
one of her close college friends
that I knew would be a big surprise
that I was able to get her to do it.
Oh yeah?
'Cause they
haven't really talked in a while,
that was the one I closed with.
Anyway, Jessie was, let me just say,
that the effect of this video,
now I know we spent all the time
talking about the celebrities,
she really, really appreciated it.
It was great.
And then she asked me,
"Did my therapist tell you
that I wanted a birthday
video like this?".
And I was like, no, no.
And I was like, "Because I told him
that that's what I was hoping
that Rhett was doing this for me,
I hope that he was making a video
because I couldn't have a party."
And I didn't know that,
I just was like, this is the next thing
besides a party to show
collective appreciation.
And you're not one for getting her gifts
that she actually wants,
you're not known for that.
Well, I don't think that's my problem
as much it's her problem,
I think she has a very high
standard, that's all I'll say.
I have whiffed on some gifts, for sure,
I've gotten better in
the past couple of years
but there was the most
pressure on this one
because it was this milestone birthday,
she wasn't able to do anything
and I was nervous,
'cause I had done the Jason Momoa thing,
I had done this video,
I also got her a bunch of other gifts,
and also the trip out of town
with you guys was a surprise,
she didn't know that was gonna
happen until the day before.
Have you paid me for that?
I keep forgetting to do
that, yeah I need to do that.
So far, it's my gift.
Yeah, yeah, we went through
your Airbnb account,
I need to do that as soon as this is over.
We could pause, you could
just do it right now.
So anyway, this really works.
Success, man.
It really worked.
Can't do it again, though,
you only turn 40 once.
Right, yeah, when she turns 50.
But you can 69,
69 times.
I can probably get there before 52.
Yeah, so this kind of
turned into, like I said,
it kind of turned into an ad
for Cameo, which it's not,
but I will make that my 'rec,
you know, I might as well,
just because I'm sure that
there's another service
or there should be, somebody
should be getting on this,
but Cameo got into this
kind of early in the game.
Again, when you think about
the inner workings of it
and somebody's just sitting
down, doing a bunch of videos,
it may seem kind of empty,
but when that person watches the video
that you've made for them,
especially if they don't
understand Cameo as a service,
they're like, I can't
believe you got this for me,
I can't believe you did this.
It's so effective, so effective.
I mean, everyone's
beginning to understand,
but it's still a pretty great thing.
First of all,
people do things like get
a star named after you,
you know what I'm saying?
It's better than that.
There's a lot of things that you can do,
like, oh, I got you an acre on the moon
or a square foot on the
moon, or something like that
that doesn't mean anything,
like, were they gonna go up there?
Think you did that for me once, actually.
I think I've done both of
those things for you as jokes
but it's a tangible thing,
it results in this video
that, like I said,
you could put on your
social media or whatever
and be like, look what
Violent J said about me
and Jessie hasn't posted that one,
but she is free to post any
of these on her social media.
Yes she is.
'Cause it's not a commercial thing.
So to wrap things up,
wishing Jessie a happy
belated 40th birthday,
and inviting you to give
a 'rec, baby, 'rec, baby,
one, two, three, four.
That was my 'rec.
Cameo?
That's what I just said,
I'm just making Cameo my 'rec.
Oh, I didn't believe that.
I had another 'rec.
Oh, okay, no, that'll work.
It's hard to come up with 'recs,
so I'm just gonna save that
for next time.
Yeah, save it.
My 'rec is, yeah, now
you know about Cameo,
if you didn't know about
it, you know how it works
and you know that I used it successfully,
so that's my 'rec.
Not a sponsor though, maybe
they should be paying us.
For real.
We'll talk at you next week, #EarBiscuits,
let us know what you
think about all of this.
Have you had a Cameo experience?
I wanna hear that.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms,
thanks for being your mythical best.